so if we all have 24 hours in a day we
all live on planet Earth and we all work
what are you doing with your time
success is walking from failure to
failure with no loss of enthusiasm
you're exactly where you're supposed to
be how many of you have led anxiety get
in your way I lived in a compromised
home and I became the fruit of that
compromised home people are spending
money you need the skill to learn how to
get them to spend it with your product
or service and most people fail to
understand that success takes time if
you want to be a millionaire you'll
learn from a millionaire you do not
learn from your uncle who's a janitor
and wherever there is fear there is no
faith wherever there is fear there is no
faith well any time you prune anything
you're gonna get much more growth if you
help other people get what they want
then you will get what you want
she's a best-selling author speaker and
TV and radio show host she's made guest
appearances on The Oprah Winfrey Show
Good Morning America and Forbes she's
the president and CEO of destiny global
she's Danny Johnson and here's my take
on her top ten rules for success so we
all have 24 hours in a day we all live
on planet Earth and we all work what are
you doing with your time because people
like a Bill Gates or the late Steve Jobs
they had lived on planet earth they had
24 hours in a day and they worked why is
it that they made so much more money
than the rest of us because there is a
variable in the equation of success and
that variable is you it's you not your
government that you're working under not
the boss not the business not the
manufacturing not the product on the
service you and what you do with what
you have you see when I first got
started in business you know as a
homeless broke fat cocktail waitress
well the business that kind of presented
itself to me if you will was actually
sitting in my back seat it was not
something
that I wanted to do but as a cocktail
waitress I knew that I'd be homeless for
another three months and I knew it I
would never pay off my $35,000 in debt
making the amount that I was making as a
cocktail waitress so I came to that
conclusion
hopefully you're coming to the same
conclusion this is not going to work I
have to find a way to generate more
income well that business that was in
the back seat of my car really wasn't a
business it was a product it was a
product that I wasn't interested in it
was a product that didn't work for me it
was a product that I had no credibility
in it was in the weight loss industry I
was fat who was gonna listen to me I'm
fat who's gonna listen to me I didn't
even like this product that's how come
we're sitting in the back of my car
instead of actually me using it well I
didn't believe in it I didn't like it it
wasn't my lifelong dream and passion it
wasn't the right business in my opinion
at that time but I had to step up and
become the right person in order to get
out of debt to make more money and to
make a change in my life rather than
waiting around for someone to sail in
and save the day yeah I had to make some
serious changes you know and that's
unfortunate because people are
struggling right now they're waiting for
someone to take the problems away
they're waiting for someone to change
the circumstances they're waiting to be
found
they're waiting for somebody to make all
the difference for them there is no
somebody actually I have to correct
myself
you are the somebody we found this quote
from Winston Winston Churchill pretty
successful man hmm pretty famous still
as famous even though he's dead success
is walking from failure to failure with
no loss of enthusiasm whoa I need to get
there walking from failure to failure
with no loss of hello enthusiasm that's
what he calls success you see success so
much is a mindset it's how we think it's
how we approach life it's the decisions
that we make and we live in a society
that is completely painted this picture
for you and me of what success looks
likes houses cars stuff right and then
we go and we charge and get mortgages
and we go into debt to get that stuff
and now
those things don't feel like success
they feel like a giant burden why
because the path in which they told us
to get those things not only that do you
really want those things think about it
do you really want those things or do
you just want them because somebody else
has told you that that's what success
looks like be careful what you ask
because there is a price for what you
want
if you ain't ready Joseph was not ready
to lead his family because there were
things in him that had to get worked out
of him just like there's things in you
that have to get worked out of you there
are things in me that have to get worked
out of me before I can get to the height
of my destiny and same for you you're
exactly where you're supposed to be
you're exactly where you're supposed to
be how many of you have led anxiety get
in your way
and how many of you through that anxiety
have gone and done other things because
things aren't going fast enough it's not
moving great enough it's not exactly
what I thought it was going to be it
doesn't look like the way I thought it
was supposed to look come on that is a
dangerous place to be I lived in a
compromised home and I became the fruit
of that compromised home and I paid the
price for that those decisions that I
made without all that program so I know
from a business perspective that I had
to pull away from all TV all bad music
so I could reprogram myself to succeed
so then naturally when I had my kids I
did the same thing with them now it
wasn't for a godly reason friends this
multi-millionaire saying do not watch
the media do not watch all that junk
that's on TV it is only going to take
you to failure look at what everybody
else is doing and do the exact opposite
everybody else is watching TV everybody
else is watching the favorite soap
everybody else is watching their
favorite stupid sitcom everyone else is
watching their favorite talk show
everyone else is just sitting there
vegetating in front of that thing and
they're listening to music that does not
groom them for success 25 years ago the
greatest gift I got was from that man
saying you want to be successful you
study success
leave everything else behind my family
was at Six Flags last weekend oh my gosh
thousands and thousands of
people spending thousands of dollars for
one day of pleasure there's the same
people that are telling you they can't
afford your product or service hello
they didn't tell six flags they couldn't
afford that expensive ticket or that $10
Slurpee give me a break
people are spending money you need the
skill to learn how to get them to spend
it with your product or service so don't
blame your spouse don't blame the kids
don't blame your past don't blame your
customers don't blame anything it's time
to step up and get the skills that you
need to succeed because at the end of
the day you're the one that has to grow
that thing you're the one that has to
pay off the debt you're the one that's
going to build that career or that
business you're the one that's going to
fix the things in the marriage you're
the one that it's all going to fall down
to so it's up to you to get what you
need so that you can succeed listen if I
can do it and the tens of thousands
before me who have done it and after me
and so can you
people have this mindset and belief that
the only way they can increase their
income is if they actually go to college
or if by chance that they meet the right
people if they get lucky they marry the
right person none of that has anything
to do with it in fact all of that is a
giant myth so is overnight success
success takes time it takes time you
know there's that certain season of the
year where a farmer or even a gardener
is planting seed in the ground it takes
time for that seed to germinate it takes
time for it to become a sprout it takes
time for it to then start to get a
little bit of strength and become a
stock and then eventually it begins to
flower and then through more time hello
more and more time at the same time
we're supposed to be nurturing that seed
I mean that sprout we're supposed to be
taking care of it caring for it feeding
it watering making sure it's not getting
too much Sun or too much cold and so
this seed takes time to go from seed to
the actual fruit it takes time some
things take longer than others and most
people fail to understand that success
takes time if you want to be successful
don't be listening to
opinions of those that are not
successful if you want to be a
millionaire you'll learn from a
millionaire you do not learn from your
uncle who's a janitor okay you don't
learn from broke people about money you
don't and we are a product of our
environment and we are who we surround
ourselves with that's the facts so the
power of programming you see everything
that you are today is who you were
trained to be you were you are trained
by a messaging that was constantly
coming through you through music through
movies through sitcoms all of that stuff
completely architected your mind and God
gave us such a powerful mind that he
says as a man thinks so is he okay
so how we think is who we become and he
also said that life and death is in the
power of the tongue so and and we will
eat the fruit of what we say so what we
say about ourselves what we say about
our kids what we say about our spouse
what we say about life about politics
what we say about money like this is a
terrible thing to teach your kids how to
say we can't afford it we don't have the
money okay I hate my job I hate mondays
I can't wait till Friday's in fact
neurologists have proven they say that
the speech center of the brain controls
your entire reality it controls your
entire reality I'm being led to do this
with you right now grab a partner I need
a bit is there any men a big man in this
room by any chance is there a big man in
the room I don't think I could do this
without a man do we have a man
now that's a big man now what were you
thinking over there ladies I feel let's
do this for you because this is a really
powerful exercise so when we say things
like I can't afford it I don't have the
money I'm fat somebody was asking me yes
you're like okay what did you please
come up what did you do okay I'm a size
six I've been a size six for the last 21
years yeah I was fifty pounds overweight
four times in four years
my mom was 300 pounds I'm sorry 280
pounds both my sisters are 300 pounds I
come from the obese family do you
understand so obesity ran on my family I
guess what I thought about myself and
guess what my killer doesn't my
stepfather said to me that I was fat I
was ugly these are the things I was told
and these are the things that by golly I
really believed and it wasn't until I
forgave my dad changed the tape of what
was rolling in my head that I no longer
acted like a fat person because if you
think you're fat what will you do come
on as a man thinks so is she as you
think so are you so I saw myself at I
spoke like I was right is this this do
so do I look fat in this is my butt too
big man I'm so fat I have this I have
that right so when you think like that
then you start to act like that that's
how it works how you think is how you
speak how you speak is how you act so
you automatically in instantly go in the
direction of what you're thinking and
speaking therefore the power of
programming sometimes the blessings of
God are completely obvious and sometimes
there's something in us that likes to
fight them sometimes we fight the
obvious why do we fight the obvious how
many of you have fought the obvious
before
how many of you found out this morning
that you fought a lot the obvious okay
you find the obvious you know what
direction you supposed to go and you
don't want to go in that direction it's
because of fear and control fear and
control is why we fight the obvious we
will either want the credit for the
success when it comes or we're afraid
that it's really not going to work and
wherever there is fear there is no faith
wherever there is fear there is no faith
you've got to have faith the reality is
is that there are inhibitors to your
goals
there really is there's real-life
inhibitors and some of those inhibitors
could be negative people yeah
negative people but I got to tell you
something negative people are people who
and critical people and judgmental
people are people who have no goals and
no dreams themselves you literally need
a fair sorry for these people because
the truth is is the out of the mouth the
heart speaks so when somebody is
inherently critical and judgmental and
condemning of someone else's dreams or
goals or aspirations or something that
they want to do it just shows you who
they really are are actually rather who
they really aren't
I used to be one of those very negative
very cynical very judgemental people and
I'm so glad that I took the steps that
were necessary for me to no longer be
that negative to be that cynical to be
that person that nobody wanted to be
around well the deer came in and ate our
squash as well as our green beans but I
gotta tell you there's good news
whenever you encounter inhibit or to
your goals something that seems to take
them away or something that seems to I
know stop the growth well in this case
the deer actually did us a favor because
now what we have is we have some pruned
green beans and we have some pruned
cucumbers what does that mean well
anytime you prune anything you're going
to get much more growth did you hear me
whenever something is pruned you get
much more growth I've already seen it
with our green beans which are right
over here
the green beams were attacked
just like the cucumbers well these were
bare just a few days ago they were bare
now look at all the new leaves that have
come on see you can kind of see still
some of the raw edges that were bit
bitten or eaten by those deer but now
what we have is they are growing again
and they're flourishing again and I even
found right down here one little green
bean I don't know if you can see that or
not but I'm hoping you can there's a
green bean so hear me friend hear me
this is the absolute and I mean absolute
truth even if it seems that some of your
goals that you feel like you've been
digressing even if it feels like you've
taken major steps backwards this is part
of the pruning process and what follows
the pruning process is much more growth
so don't get distracted with this
negative people don't get discouraged if
those deer have come in and eaten some
of your vines
the truth is keep pressing keep moving
forward if you help other people get
what they want then you will get what
you want if your button habit heads
against your boss your boss wants to see
you succeed but if you care more about
your boss's success than you do your own
your Father in Heaven who sees all that
you do and all that you don't do will
bless you that's the key to prosperity
is to focus on somebody else's
prosperity first and yours will come as
a direct result of theirs being there
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Roxanne Fraser asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
10 rules today meant the most to you
what changes you're going to make in
your business as a result leave it in
the comments and I will join in the
discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon
you